[Applauso]
nuova normalità se ne sente impararle in
continuazione
che cosa ne pensate della nuova
normalità
un frullatore ecco proviamo a immaginare
la nuova normalità come un frullatore
beh perché in fondo se ci pensate
siamo stati un po tutti shakerati siamo
stati scellerati a livello individuale a
livello micro da una nuova normalità
fatta di mascherine da una nuova
normalità fatta di distanza sociale da
una nuova normalità fatta di smart work
a livello macro siamo stati un po
shakerati da una nuova normalità fatta
di innovazione tecnologica che corre a
una velocità e una portata come mai
viste prima
una nuova normalità fatta di cambiamenti
climatici repentini una nuova normalità
fatta di movimenti attivisti
internazionali che stanno lottando
contro il razzismo stanno cercando di
elevare il ruolo della donna il ruolo
della diversità e dell'inclusione
tutte queste dinamiche
fanno parte della nuova normalità
e allora io oggi provo a farvi una
provocazione proviamo a pensare a questa
nuova normalità come un frullatore e se
facciamo questa cosa ne scatta
immediatamente un'altra riflettere sugli
ingredienti quali sono gli ingredienti
della nuova normalità sicuramente ognuno
di voi ha degli ingredienti diversi
sicuramente ci sono dei mix delle dosi
completamente diverse che cosa c'è in
questo frullatore lo vedremo sicuramente
ci sono degli ingredienti che ci
scegliamo consapevolmente o
inconsapevolmente ma li scegliamo ci
sono poi altri ingredienti una pandemia
tutta la serie di implicazioni che si
porta dietro che cambiano il sapore
della nostra normalità
ma li dobbiamo usare non se ne può fare
a meno frullatore ingredienti
proviamo a pensare alla nuova normalità
come a un frullatore gigantesco molto
più grande di questo magari anche un
pochino più moderno
chi lo sa e proviamo a fare questo
esercizio
ecco qua se la ride come ci comportiamo
di fronte alla nuova normalità il primo
ingrediente sul cui su cui vorrei
riflettere e relativo proprio ai
comportamenti
cosa facciamo come reagiamo cosa succede
alle nostre abitudini
nella nuova normalità io mi occupo di
marketing studiare il comportamento
umano
mi piace pensare a un comportamento
umano prima che ha un comportamento del
consumatore studiare i comportamenti è
parte del mio lavoro e vi dirò che è
anche parte della mia passione e il
lavoro mi ha permesso di fronteggiare
tante di avere di fronte e tante nuove
normalità una nuova normalità fatta di
diversi luoghi dove abitare roma milano
new york una nuova normalità fatta di
persone di culture diverse buone
normalità fatte di aziende diverse in
cui ho lavorato di sfide diverse
ecco allora che i miei comportamenti le
mie reazioni nei confronti delle diverse
normalità che mi sono trovato ad
affrontare
hanno fatto aumentare ancora di più la
passione per cercare di capire che cosa
succede perché facciamo quello che
facciamo cosa c'è dietro ai nostri
comportamenti
sei anni fa mi sono trasferita in
america mi sono trovata di fronte a una
nuova normalità e soprattutto mi sono
trovata di fronte all'obbligo guardando
ai miei comportamenti di riprogrammare
le mie abitudini
sicuramente nuove abitudini mi sono
ritrovata ad abitare a new york con una
nuova realtà un nuovo appartamento in un
palazzo che conteneva almeno la metà
delle persone che abitano nel paese dove
sono cresciuta nuove culture nuove
amicizie nuovi colleghi nuove sfide
beh io posso dirvi che a distanza di sei
anni e mezzo dal trasferimento c'è una
sfida che ricordo con un sorriso ma che
ricordo come la sfida che un po
simboleggia il mio trasferimento in
america si tratta del cambio automatico
sì perché in america le auto con il
cambio automatico sono la normalità così
come in italia sono la normalità
le auto con il cambio manuale ora ho
sentito qualche sorrisino la mia più
grande sfida è stata quella di
riscrivere vent'anni di abitudini
vent'anni di automatismi da guida
manuale imparando a guidare una macchina
con il cambio automatico
fa sorridere lo so è banale queste sono
a volte le sfide più grandi
ne ho avute altre di molto maggiori se
volete ma se penso alla nuova normalità
della mia americas penso immediatamente
al cambio automatico e a questa
riscrittura delle abitudini e se ci
pensate
questo è quello che è successo con la
quando è mio la pandemia
ci ha obbligato a riscrivere tutte le
nostre routine le nostre abitudini
quotidiane
i piani a medio termine e cambiare i
comportamenti è una cosa estremamente
complessa sofisticata e soprattutto
parliamo di nuova normalità ma la nuova
normalità è fluida
noi non siamo arrivati è uno stato
mentale è una situazione parleremo super
sempre magari è troppo ma parleremo
molto di nuova normalità è importante
soffermarsi a riflettere su quelli che
sono i nostri comportamenti
è importante a livello personale è
importante per i professionisti per le
aziende capire come si stanno evolvendo
i mercati capire come si stanno
evolvendo i consumatori capire e cercare
di individuare quello che è così una
moda del momento da un trend cosa
rimarrà cosa resterà nel futuro cosa non
c'è ancora che verrà immaginato ecco
queste sono alcune domande estremamente
interessanti e che riguardano un
ingrediente i nostri comportamenti
le neuroscienze ci dicono che dal 40 al
95 per cento dei nostri comportamenti
può essere raggruppato nella sfera delle
abitudini capite quant'è importante
capire e andare ad investigare che cosa
succede nella nostra mente ed è per
questo che a un gancio per un altro
ingrediente come pensiamo la nuova
normalità
abbiamo visto come ci comportiamo ma
come pensiamo la nuova normalità ve lo
siete mai chiesti la maggior parte dei
nostri pensieri
l'ottanta per cento delle nostre
attività mentali avviene sotto la soglia
della nostra coscienza
noi ci comportiamo per automatismi la
gran parte
e allora facciamo un passo indietro
siamo partiti dai comportamenti
cominciamo andare un passo indietro dice
ok il comportamento è visibile cosa c'è
dietro c'è un pensiero e allora questo
secondo ingrediente parla di unconscious
byas di pregiudizi inconsci
inconsapevoli di automatismi della
nostra mente qualcosa che succede al di
fuori del nostro controllo
quella cosa che immediatamente vi ha
fatto avere un'immagine di me per il
solo fatto di avere i capelli rosa
immediatamente appena vi ho messo il
primo passo forse il primo passo solito
l'oro delle scarpe
forse immediatamente istintivamente
inconsciamente la vostra mente ha fatto
un collegamento per che ha visto un
capello rosa quale collegamento la
vostra mente ha fatto io non lo so
da parte mia mi sono solo preparata a
questo evento facendo il colore
prendendo un vestito ma l'elefante nella
stanza non è il vestito il capello e
quello che avete pensato l'automatismo
che è scattato nella vostra mente deriva
dalla vostra storia dalla vostra
famiglia dalla condizione sociale dove
siete vissuti dal livello di educazione
che vi è stato dato o che vi siete
formati dal livello delle esperienze da
quante volte vi è capitato di parlare
con una persona con i capelli rosa da
quante volte ve ne hanno parlato sono
tutti automatismi usiamo i miei capelli
rosa come esempio non preoccupatevi ne
sono abituata ai capelli rosa da due
anni ma se vi dicessi che i capelli rosa
li uso un po come un test se vi dicessi
che dietro il mio cappello rosa in
realtà fa io faccio delle mie
personalissime ricerche di mercato
il cappello rosa il tempo
del capello rosa si focalizza su un
battito di ciglia questo battito di
ciglia è impercettibile e
affascinantissimo dovete sapere che mi
affascina incredibilmente perché è un
battito di ciglia che è lo specchio di
un pregiudizio è fantastico perché ora
scherziamo sul cappello rosa e va bene
così
ma i nostri pregiudizi influenzano la
percezione della realtà i nostri
pregiudizi influenzano i nostri
comportamenti
possiamo ridere sul capello rosa ma che
succede se scambiamo il capello rosa con
il colore della pelle
se cambiamo un capello rosa per una
provenienza geografica per non lo so
una preferenza di tipo sessuale per una
preferenza di tipo di gender chi lava i
piatti in casa che apparecchia chi
cucina possiamo andare dai massimi
sistemi ai minimi termini dal macro al
micro sempre di pregiudizi paghiamo i
nostri comportamenti hanno dei byas le
ricerche ce lo dicono non dobbiamo
sentirci in difficoltà per questo ho
delle persone meno buone ci sono dei
byas dei pregiudizi positivi ci sono dei
byas negativi ma dobbiamo esserne o
proviamo possiamo provare ad esserne
coscienti questa la grossa differenza
tutti abbiamo i nostri byas pensare alla
nostra normalità alla nuova normalità
significa iniziare ad essere sempre più
consapevoli degli unconscious byas dei
comportamenti impliciti e inconsci che
si collegano i nostri comportamenti e
significa
una volta riconosciuti cominciare a
correggerli questo ci aiuta nella nuova
normalità
vediamo un po cosa c'è qui ultimo
ingrediente per oggi non potevano
mancare cosa proviamo
nella nuova normalità
qual è come sta la nostra sfera emotiva
che cosa proviamo di fronte a un
incertezza dilagante stiamo vivendo una
situazione senza precedenti
ricorderò sempre io vivo a times square
ricorsi
ricorderò sempre il silenzio assordante
dei mesi di marzo aprile
viviamo in un incertezza senza
precedenti lavoro da casa da cinque mesi
ho cambiato quattro case due continenti
ho riscritto le mie abitudini
ho testato pregiudizi ho cercato di
ampliare la mia sfera delle emozioni
parlare di emozioni mi riporta al
concetto ad un film a un film animato
della disney pixar inside out in cui ci
sono tutti i personaggi che
simboleggiano la mente e le emozioni di
riley questa ragazzina che dal minnesota
è costretta a trasferirsi a san
francisco e il film spettacolare per
darci così una visione di quello che
succede nella nostra mente la nuova
normalità la nuvola nostra nuova
normalità è un po simile a quello che
sta vivendo lo hai lì in cui la sua
mente i suoi comportamenti sono
governati dalle emozioni emozioni
positive emozioni negative un turbinio
di emozioni
va bene così ascoltiamo le anche le
emozioni negative fanno parte del nostro
mix ascoltiamole impariamo ad aumentare
la nostra consapevolezza emotiva anche
le emozioni sono un ingrediente
la mentale allora io oggi vi ho parlato
vi ho invitato a guardare alla nuova
normalità come a un frullatore abbiamo
parlato di ingredienti come ci
comportiamo come pensiamo come ci
sentiamo ovviamente gli ingredienti non
finiscono qui ci sono tantissimi
ingredienti ognuno ha i suoi ingredienti
ognuno ha il suo mix pensate alla
creatività
pensate alla curiosità all'attitudine
positiva la lista degli ingredienti è
infinita
e allora io vi lascio con un invito
l'invito è quello a esplorare a
sperimentare ad espandere la vostra
lista degli ingredienti perché da un
frullatore e da una da un mix di
ingredienti possiamo ottenere un
risultato la confidenza nell'immaginare
il nostro modo per cavalcare la nuova
normalità grazie
[Applauso]